you don't you don't want any more james
earl jones he died
when did he die he died didn't he james
jones died
no he didn't the hell neil
no i'm telling you i'm gonna murder him
okay it was like
[Music]
hey everybody we were talking [ __ ]
right before this
this bit that we're doing here no no
that
i have a story about this bit oh tell me
um
this is uh this is uh snl
historian neil brennan it's not even
historian this is whatever the [ __ ] i
was just thinking we were talking before
the
before this aired that i'm like neil's a
comedic history last 30 years
i would say before the cliff nestor off
is
across the board like actual rights
books right
so that bit we were just doing did you
ever see fred armisen and kristen wiig
do that bid on sorry live yes
so while they were doing it in like
0.809
seth was hosting update and i go you
know what that bit
could use you should say
hey this seems like you guys are
fred it seems like you're making this up
and chris and it seems like you're
trying to follow along
which would have because it would get
like half
laughs because the audience didn't quite
understand yeah it was a it like didn't
land
yeah it's like [ __ ] hilarious but the
artist doesn't know what they're looking
at
says like i cannot say that to them
which is just like the way snl works
where you can't but that would just be a
good note
yes but you can't note people
why if uh it's just the rules
because it would get too messy too it'd
be like oh
yeah like no we got it like what i don't
think that fred would you know they'd be
fun but it just
and then um and and then
at somebody's wedding who i won't say
whose wedding because it's not it's not
going great according to the tabloids
uh i say to so then fred does a similar
bit
okay on seth's show
where they they make up books and they
go fred do you know what that's about
and he's very clearly
and seth says i think you're making this
up and then the cut they always cut to
fred and it's always [ __ ] hilarious
and i said to fred the note i gave seth
he's like
why didn't he say that so it's always
worse than you think
in your head's like no i don't want to
say it i don't know of course well it's
i get it but i just
it the fact that he was he's like i
would have
you're right and i would have absolutely
done it
that's show business for you guys and
that is a story about the show
hollywood is not involving black people
very much fred is a little black latino
he's a bunch of stuff i don't know what
he is you know i always got him
and al magical confused a lot
like insult to al's good looking
al is good-looking yeah al's good
looking and fred's
uh interesting looking yeah but i could
see he's like not
bad looking no they're both like manly
in a weird way
fred is so [ __ ] funny he's it's like
on it's like
[ __ ] it's crazy neil made a very good
[ __ ] um so bianca
yeah how's your week that's pretty good
what'd you get into it
i want to i went to a roast of our
friend yeah
from the comedy store is leaving and i
didn't go to the roast because
i am sensitive and
if anyone had made a joke about me and i
wasn't
they i it's like when you go to roast
you're like going to a gun range and
it's like you might get shot so
it's like a very disorganized gun range
and
i i didn't want to get shot
supporting adam you know what i mean
like [ __ ]
like damage like what the [ __ ] am i
doing
uh so yeah um it was very funny and it
just felt like one of those
old-school rose no cameras no recording
just
very inside baseball no joke out to be
explained no joke went over anyone's
head some people bombed
it was awful that's always there's
always one there's always one where
you're like
but it was it was better like it was
nice that that person bombed we all
bonded on their bomb the worst
greatest rose story of all time is there
was a
somebody was roommates this is in new
york it's in the 90s
and somebody or the early thousands
somebody had made an snl audition with
like characters and all this stuff
and was roommates with another comic and
they
showed the audition tape at the roast
just as like without just excruciating
just the
one of the meanest things you can do
and reminds me of a age-old
philosophical question
would you rather find out that your
girl does or your girlfriend
did porn or that's on
pornhub or would you rather find out
that your girlfriend
has a a a compilation of characters
on youtube it's a tough one isn't it
it's a toughie a lot of wigs or just
an another fella
doing it to her which would you which
would be easier to deal with long term
nine different characters none of them
very good what you have to answer
porn i'm gonna go porn i'd rather
she have done porn yeah i'm the older i
get the less
uh jealous i am just understanding
of just like i wasn't there right it's
not like you
left me to yeah [ __ ] this person
right i don't especially in the age of
wait so you were jealous
oh yeah i used to be very jealous no
like um
i can't imagine not jealous like where
were you right
more uh like sexual
um theater
uh like
she was having she had more fun in the
past or dumb [ __ ] like that like i don't
[ __ ]
at this point it's like i now i'm like
well how'd that go
where is he okay what about if you
there was a dinner party and she was
laughing a lot with like
other comedians you know and not that
much with you
that i that i could very quickly
recognize
was a smallness issue
that was based on nothing like right
yeah i don't know
they were thinking why are you
of all people so chris rock does it for
you like
[ __ ] they're funny oh that's that's
why i'm friends with them like
that's good like i that didn't ever
that was never an issue for me it wasn't
real-time jealousy it was just like
they had more fun with an ex
sexual they were they i was not as good
at sex as somebody else
right very interesting yeah just not
even in character really right like
just like that oh that sounds like a
neil problem i don't know i it was just
a thing that i would
that i would uh not fix it but but it's
just aware
yeah interesting stupid [ __ ] stupid
question
yeah are there rules in a roast
in a roast uh
in general is there like can you go
too far well is it like a wrap
uh not
really because even rap battles
pusha t said all that stuff about like
drake
but people were like he went too far
tests and all that i mean it was about
saying your friends dying that was like
oh you got him um you got him good
um i don't know if it's well
said it's if it's if it's a
well-structured joke
i can have at it yeah but if it's
beyond if it's like
this is an snl this is an old snl story
come on uh
that bill murray one time yelled at
chevy chase
pointed at him and said medium talent
which is really which is like
the ruder than anything your mommy
medium talent is like
[ __ ] that is damning that's
you guys you just that's the yeah that's
the comic kryptonite if you want to get
a comic
yeah well medium talent yeah it's just
it anyone
call a girl five yeah but
comics appear to be a lot harder to
insult than well they were
fighting that uh chevy and murray were
fighting oh that was like
they were like i mean they used to have
fist fights like they
were like real 70s [ __ ] right
there'd be like a chimp there for no
reason because it's the 70s
yeah uh so medium talent is
that's that's almost too far to me like
that's like hey
there's ways to say that that i can
trick myself into thinking
aren't what that right like that but
medium talent's a tough one medium
talent's on me it's not the industry
doesn't like it's just medium talents
like
oof um i want to say
patrice called jessalik
mediocre which is wrong but somebody
patrice had a thing
in that region about justin like on the
rose of patrice the roast of uh
i don't remember who was that but that
was the one yeah that they were both on
what uh was it after bts no it was
on the dates interesting
yeah i don't think it was just like
you're a waiter you look like you're
like a waiter at
medieval times it was just sort of even
that's jokey so
yeah it's like it's fine um yeah so so i
did that and then
my friend had a birthday and it was very
nice it felt like
it was she she hired a cellist
hmm interesting somebody's old i know
and
we had brunch and i just i kept calling
it black bridgeton
like isn't the kid on bridges and play
yeah
hmm but not everybody it was a white
culture
not everyone was black everyone was
black in this french never gonna watch
one frame
of bridgerton yeah don't care lord lord
brennan
no yeah does nothing for me i just don't
care i don't i don't i you know i don't
watch it it's honestly
it's barely for me if you watch it it's
like this is easy
watching if he wasn't black would you
care oh yeah i
like like dumbs and abby i like the
channel yeah so that's what i'm saying
like it's something
it feels a bit you can be diverse but
that's i don't know i don't want to say
girly
but i want to do a joke about diverse
casting where
they want us to be like they'll
they'll have like a judge show and it'll
be like
it'll be like a 45 year old black lady
and they want all of us to be like
black judge like
black folks how do you guys think of a
black dress like
they're so proud of it like and we
made her black um
anyhow uh what did i do i did
i did spots on
[Music]
thursday and saturday where
improv and um
store and uh
out uh jamming the van outdoor thingy
and it was great it's fun and
stand-up comedy is endlessly fascinating
that's kind of the only [ __ ] i did
that was like you know stuff stuff stuff
so that's the only time i left the house
and i went to a whole foods yesterday
how was that and you can use your own
you can bring your own bag again guys
fyi you had to use paper bags there for
a while for about a year
bring your own bag they won't let me
ever bag my they for
that was hard for me because i'm like i
i'll bag it's like
you're not allowed yeah you can't go
back there now i will bag
my own groceries i don't like when they
bag it well i have some good news
what the venice store venice blew it
out venice was already the flagship it's
they've
added a deck to the flagship in what way
uh
they just cleared out a bunch it's
they just opened up what feels like
a football field to the left
when you walk in like there's so they
just i don't know they just moved a
bunch of [ __ ]
uh and self-checkout
self-checkout is i love it i take my
time i'm like don't look at me
go around me i'm will be here for you
it's a slower it's slow
and the problem is they have fruit and
you can't
i typed in the number yeah and they're
like that we don't recognize so then you
have to go
mango red mango yellow mango
organic yellow right then
their fault that's it right but i i
think i cheated
but i didn't do it i was like i don't
know i don't remember i just go to the
quickest if it's organic or not i'm like
green onion have you checked out
oh i love it uh yeah yeah by yourself no
with no with my mommy and daddy no no
i'm saying it's a new
it's like the check out the
self-checkout opened yesterday uh
the one in downtown l.a has been been
done driving been done had one hand
thriving oh well you know it's because i
don't know if you know this i used to
work at whole foods oh
z or an o.j you type your type in your
slide your laminate
in there and follow bananas
she still has it everybody she's still
got it you still got it
um anyhow the week
it was a pretty it wasn't a wild week
um in the world yeah i'd like to say
right now
we're not even talking about israel or
palestine because it's just we're not i
got
i got nothing to add we're good things
i got nothing to add what do you think i
think
that's what i think and then another
question what do you want me to think
i also think that uh it's funny i like
none of our none of our lists we put
together we both know each other and
neither of us want to talk about it like
cause it's just like it's a [ __ ]
it's a bog it's just a mud bog yeah
and there's no way for us
to do any justification by
publicly trying to sort through this
thing that no one can sort through it i
have a whole social media plan which is
never i don't think i'm ever gonna make
a public
declaration ever again thank god because
it's [ __ ] stupid
it's just stupid it's dumb it's it's
it's like the amount of
uh just there's too much ignorance i
don't mean it and i just mean honestly
just not knowing information
mm-hmm so then you put uh
and then public declarations are just
and i for the record why is this it's
fine no one cares i'll give you jokes
on my page what do you want what do you
that's what i have i have jokes give it
to us
so it seems it's pretty good
it's been pretty good for a while guys
you've liked them pretty consistently so
just
keep liking them thank you
historically
um the mass what do you make of the mask
she's smoking no um i
i the cdc is
weird it's easy it seems
i feel like they have a pr operation
it's i they
it seemed like they had stuff
it just seems disorganized it seems like
there are two different people
that's what i mean who are struggling
for
messaging right and then that one won
and then
and then the other one it's like
actually no well why don't we release
the third why wait
[ __ ] it well you wait cause
you have to get everyone because i went
to the store
for instance the comedy store and ever
i'm like do i wear one
no now you're getting listen i've been
getting shamed you don't need
you could put oh now yeah you shame for
like for having the mask
they want you to take it off it's so
weird like why do you care
if i'm wearing one you're it makes you
feel bad
if that's what it is it makes people
feel bad about their choice it reminds
me of when
i lived in panama i when i sat in the
backseat every time i saw the backseat i
put on my seatbelt everyone
no no no no perfect perfect
i'm like gonna do it for safety
everyone said
everyone was like it's
so [ __ ] i mean the production
yes the guy flew to jamaica to do it
in bob marley's studio it's unbelievable
um
i was like so the law says the person in
the front seat has to have your seat
built on mm-hmm
what's prevent what's uh why can't they
have them back here
i've as somebody who's worn a seat belt
in
taxis for 30 years because
i dated a girl who she
got no a thing and had a [ __ ] scar on
her forehead from just being in the back
seat
and getting popped she's going on an
accident and she has a giant's garden
and
and i was like yeah why do i why am i
hot dogging back there
like why am i hot dogging like people
women are going to be like
that guy's not wearing it as i drive by
in a cab the woman's like
a girl lowers her sunglasses like who's
that just that hot dog
wearing no seed going bareback
it's just funny to me because when i
thought about like you guys have a high
rate of
like uh you know vehicle mortality i
don't know what the exact statistic is
in panama in latin america it's just a
high rate thailand
it's off the hook oh yeah there are more
talks and uh mopeds and it's like the
highest vortex it's so [ __ ] crazy
but yeah so i it kind of is the
psychology of masks it's like you don't
need yeah if we all don't wear them
half the people had them on half the
people had them off and it's like well
it's california
california's in america still right
right we also do
have daily coven infection rates and
deaths
they're just very low yeah they're
really low especially the death rate
it's very though but it's still
higher than other parts of the world
yeah yeah i don't there's no
advantage to not wearing a mask
especially because uh
like what do you i don't i just don't
it's gonna be confusing for a year
my friends um parents
are flight attendants they've been five
times for a long time and they just only
do
they're i think they only do china and
australia
and so now they're still doing um
flights routes to australia and they say
that you know will you do me a favor
apologize to australians again because
we got more
notes and letters i know a guy came at
me
for saying the highest the most in uh
deadliest spider actually only lives in
sydney
but meanwhile somebody else sent me an
email saying that there
there was an email saying there have
been no deaths listen then somebody
dm'd me saying there's like no snakes
what are you worried about
i'm like uh taipans and he's like
there's no taipans
in australia they're only in india and
then i just screenshotted like
taipan's like that are literally only
from west austria i'm like i don't like
you guys i don't i don't think
no everybody no one's clear on the
the deadly animals in australia
i watch nature dogs they tell me there's
this one called like top the world's
deadliest
and the intro to each like number 10
number nine is they do an outline of
their country everything is like
australia
i'm like it's there's deadly things
there guys yeah but like
far far out okay you were saying they
fly they fly to
australia and china ah so in australia
they have to like they are met off the
plane
with a police officer that walks them to
they're escorted
oh they're not i'll show you they are
absolutely not playing
they're not playing at all there's no
they're free they're open in australia
yeah but
you still got it first no not them first
two weeks got it
i'm not the only other thing at all
they're they're
you are going to a hotel and you can
only open your door
for food and like they can't you cannot
leave the hotel
you have to take i think they provide
you with underwear and [ __ ] like because
you
if you don't you can't do laundry right
so
i don't know it's just weird that other
countries similar to america and very
nice countries that i'm sure lovely to
visit
uh are taking it so seriously still and
they have extremely low covered rates
uh america thinks it's cool to live with
a certain amount of mortality
like they truly do like well that's a
little risky
yeah look we're having a roast later you
might get shot
um but that's just the price of the game
sugar um i got
i was vindicated but not even vindicated
because i i know it was a good idea but
it
validated i don't know if you remember
me saying that they should have a
lottery
for anyone who gets vaccinated powerball
yeah
ohio did it
[Music]
you know i i saw an interview with the
governor of new jersey
and he was asked okay well how are you
going to promote that your state has a
low rate of vaccine yes
and they have all these
it's embarrassing what they have to do
they have to make these sayings they're
not gonna
they're making these sayings referring
to like the jersey shore you can't get
the shore they're doing i don't know
barbecues and
meatball giveaway i don't know what
they're doing but it's very
silly uh like come to our fair
yes um they well they but uh like
60 to 70 percent of people said
anti-vax people said oh i'll do it for
money
yeah like they're all it's they'll do it
they just wanna it's my it's the thing i
said a year ago it's my brother tommy
saying i gotta poo and do my laundry
they'll do it but they just have to make
you
so everyone receives beg for it
everyone receives and it's federal
covered relief funds they're getting the
money from
there's a weekly lottery starting may
26th
for those 17 and younger who have gotten
that's gonna be 17 and older
i don't think they want an 11 year old
getting a million dollars uh
oh the the five they'll receive a for
under 17 you get a
full four year scholarship to state of
ohio university
uh which includes tuition room and board
and books dewine announced
and old people get a million dollars
to pay off the 400 000 dollars you have
in college
loan debt um yeah so
do you think this is okay good or is it
good i just
it's like what what are people like
money let's do it if i had a kid
i was gonna do a thing where just
incentivize it
get an a i in fact i tried to work that
out with my parents like
if i get a's can i not pay for
that class hey what do you mean i when i
went to college you had to pay
yeah not i mean they have they helped
you yeah
um but i was like could i not
would they say i don't remember
i i did it wouldn't work it didn't work
yeah um but
it would have worked in high school if
it was a good amount of money because
if you just incentive people are
incentivized by
money period that's it like yeah so
with that in mind
but don't isn't there a risk that if you
incentive incentivize everything with
money
you're raising kind of an [ __ ] no you
know what i mean
no because i don't know like everything
you work in [ __ ]
no no look at all these [ __ ] going
to work you entitle [ __ ]
sit and become a bad boy but some people
do
you don't have chappelle residuals like
me you [ __ ] selfish bum
some people just do things i know people
who
will just help you out and i know people
who will
like a free meal at the end of a
hellbout
oh my you're mistaking
helping someone move for for
college or for education if
education you're trying to get
smart so that you can get a good job
period that no one's doing it for
uh i want knowledge no one's at all
so you know they're not there for
analysis they're there to
seem smart regurgitate [ __ ] for tests
and then
get a job that pays over x amount of
dollars
and so just start them early
your job is to get a's
period and b's you get subtract you know
you and then you just make it i think it
would work
but what do i know just a
kidless just a child free
uh having a blast loving every minute of
it
um and there is no one that does it
better
i didn't love the cuts of the you all i
needed was the cream of the crop
that's all we needed and welding put the
cream
right to the top beautiful that's all we
needed that's good that's all we ever
needed
swing and a mist
now bill gates dude yeah bill gates
wow who knows billionaires were dirtbags
who knew i mean at a certain point
don't it's what i was saying last week
these men do [ __ ] men achieve [ __ ] and
get money
so that they can make women more
attracted to them
like that's it yeah that's it
we need a little more on that because
it's not clear it just sounds like
piano the train is leaving or something
yeah there we go um so it's a syndicated
story it's what he's trying to get out i
know
um the
just we just need to acknowledge that
that's why men do things are you
surprised
not even a little bit i mean not even a
little bit like he
is not interested in other women i don't
know
uh because women
confuse attractio attractiveness level
with horniness
it's so he just doesn't wear it like a
dirt bag
right and he's a he's a dork doesn't
mean he doesn't
need to uh look dorks need to ejaculate
also
i'm trying to put this in a sexy way as
possible dorks
need to ejaculate too the
number two um they so yeah
he needs sexual attention he needs
physical touch
he needs to attack words of affirmation
yeah he needs words of affirmation
uh so andy's
so rich and he's
um like
solving malaria they'll let the guy [ __ ]
around a little bit
right you know what i mean well we don't
know i mean maybe that was
maybe it's like you you [ __ ] around a
lot and
right i asked we had to talk yes you
said i'm not going to do it anymore.
then you keep doing it yeah and then i
already suggested let's divorce and you
said no no no i won't do anymore baby
this is the last time that was it that
was it yeah then you did you know
yes but guys can be maybe
but probably not maybe i mean there was
a story first of all
anyone who thinks that he has any
control over the
world with microchips look at the press
he's getting he can't even get a good
[ __ ] article written about him
uh like melinda is in charge of the
press at this point melinda
got there first or something or like
promise donations to these people
because this [ __ ] is getting
pummeled in the pr battle
i know it's very but that goes to show
even if you do all these good things
that bill gates has done
you're still a celebrity it's the same
celebrity rules yeah but it's also
it's a little more fun because like that
dork needs to ejaculate
yeah yep yep yep yep yep
um and and uh
and so i just
think that it's like he's stupid for
knowing
he's stupid for not realizing what he's
like these guy because apparently he was
hitting on women
he may have had a carve out in the
relationship where he got to hang out
with
uh old female friend of his once a year
for like
yeah they went on each trip vacation
yeah
so maybe that was the one he was allowed
and then the rest of them are were
were a bridge too far um
but just fellas just admit did
you can't get married hoping
going to be a different person do you do
you
like ejaculating
i'm can't stop saying it i love it no do
you like ejaculating
is your wife going to support that
amount of ejaculation
and i i and if she's
yes and if she's not if she's not
don't marry her whether and i don't even
know if
bill gates has to [ __ ] every day let's
say he has to [ __ ] every day
he's just like greek basically like a
greek or like a puerto rican
um i went double i went greek and puerto
rican so you can't really it's not
anything um and
if melinda liked [ __ ] once a week
right what
should he be allowed to do because like
you hear stories about castro
apparently castro [ __ ] two different
women every day
every single day they would deliver
women to castro
and the google castro sex and the
previous
were two other women and the day before
that
uh it was two other women before that
and two other women
and uh this is in gq
he he what did it say he slept with 35
000 women um so
yeah well now is that
is that right yeah two women a day a
lunch dinner and sometimes
breakfast sometimes he's like me he
doesn't
not crazy about morning morning morning
sex
so is that if there are
35 000 of those women were genuinely
willing
what's the problem is there a problem i
do
i'd love to ask him is that fulfilling
when you look back at it
i'll answer for him yes yes
if you don't believe in romantic
this idea of fidelity and this is coming
from
old jealous jealous guys aj um
go ahead what do you what do you it's
that
here's the thing about guys bill gates
would do that too if he could
100 i would do it more most guys would
do that if they could
question but and women know this and
still
a lot of women don't think that i i
think we have the notion that hey guys
we'll cheat guys we'll seek other
partners at some point or whatever but i
don't think
women know that that's extreme
women know that i don't think women know
that you guys have the desires
another thought you know the thing where
if uh will you look up
if women if men knew about women the
world would split in two
very good this case good job it's an old
quote
you didn't even make it uh that was good
uh yeah right there right there right
there it's muriel reicheiser
brockheiser what what would happen if
one woman told the truth about her life
the world would split open
it's not the same the same no no no same
as what it's the same thing
um the same thing would happen if women
know
what to your point that you've made
before
that if it's the amount
and the scenario of sex that is so
troubling about guys right the amount
it's like if women knew
it would the world would split open i
think like take the hottest men
right now celebrity wise if we could
just scroll through
all the people they [ __ ] just photos of
them we would
think something was wrong with them her
oh yeah
you [ __ ] her yeah brad pitt has [ __ ]
unattractive women
fives fours fours on the road
on location and so we just have a very
weird version of each other
you know in our heads yeah you always
think women are these theories
angels yeah you know
and women think i don't know they we
accept
a beast mode out of guys but i don't
think we know the
perversion and uh i don't think we
realize how perverted guys are
like when i saw that he hung out with
epstein i was like i get that i get that
as a if you're him epstein is
fascinating
yeah he's a little cool even though he's
i'm talking that yeah when guys
married guys be like who are you with
right now you like like it's like
they're [ __ ] prisoners
yeah it's like that's what are you right
just give me one story
really yes that's so gross yeah like
come on what do you
show me a picture okay do you think that
is because
okay well here's the thing what if the
wife is nice and she's happy and she
wants to [ __ ] you is it because
the monotony of one vagina and one
person or is it that that person
grows to not want to [ __ ] you as much
that that's the probably the biggest
issue
the the they she doesn't want to [ __ ]
you anymore
and or the thing that you need to do
for her to want to [ __ ] you is like i i
go to war
i got us a house i got and now
that's just the beginning right now i
have to be
uh i have to add this like uh additional
level
of like uh
everyone does quickies neil come on uh
no i feel like married people have
pretty
not romance sex you know pretty like
ejaculatory yes but
the amount that men need to ejaculate
more is more than women
so women only need to squirt so often
that's not pretty bad
what amount of your ejaculation is my
problem and what amount of your
ejaculation
i love the category is your problem
because not not your needs don't have to
be met a hundred percent all the time i
mean
no one's a that's a bra right so what do
i do with my needs
well what part of your needs is you
being
i don't know i know but let's say i just
like
i need need want to have an orgasm
ejaculate we call it um i need to
ejaculate
once a day okay uh
there aren't too many wives who are
gonna support that
so are you what are you gonna support
in terms of masturbation and what are
you going to support
in terms of feeling
my need to feel desired because i women
also feel a need to be desired
so question if let's say
do you think a guy fought let's say four
days
are met and you have three days of on
your own ejaculation first of all you
[ __ ]
go ahead it's on my i'm on my own you're
on your own for
three days of your ejaculation and
you're i got you from byoe bring your
own ejaculation
go ahead what
is that fair or do you think
that it's i should get it the market the
market
my guess is the marriage market if you
could find a
wife who was legitimately gonna
help you have an orgasm help you
ejaculate four days a week that would be
top of the market really that i believe
that would be absolute tippy the tippy
top that's eight a5 wagyu yeah
cause i'm like what i feel like married
people [ __ ] a lot
but what they don't [ __ ] a lot
at all i mean i hear guys say
it's a nightmare romano used to do a
joke about
that when his wife when him and his wife
had sex he knew it was time to do his
quarterly taxes
and when she went down on him he knew it
was time to renew his driver's license
it's a great job uh and
it's absolutely true it will work every
night somehow
somehow somehow despite the fact that
married people out here [ __ ] a lot
they were doing it every night they'll
[ __ ] a lot when she wants to have a baby
because then it's about servicing her
needs but when it's about his disgusting
filthy needs get the [ __ ] out of here
and then sometimes in relationships the
girl really wants to have sex and the
guy doesn't want him
you know that happens yeah and that
happens also um
i think no thoughts on that no they no
moving on
um um well it would have been nice to
play the song but whatever
um in post i'm sure you'll see sure
you'll yeah you didn't bring it in the
that's a post machine you have that on
the other machine
um yeah that is
i think rarer and i think part of it is
guys it's that thing of i don't want to
have to do all the stuff to make you
want to have sex with me
if women want the ceremony often
but i don't think guys want to give the
ceremony interesting
and also if if you're living in a
business relationship where it's just
nothing but contempt
it's like uh yeah that okay what are we
doing right
okay now i'm [ __ ] were you were you
laying down
where are we doing the husbandry today
you know what i think i
i think at different power levels
because i don't think a traditional
monogamous relationship with wife kids
house vacations well
i don't think that works for a
billionaire
it just doesn't seem because
it doesn't have to well yeah but it also
just seems like his world's so much
bigger
than this this is my house my family
come home
i i think at different power levels you
might need different
family structures or relationships they
don't but this
we we're talking about this later kobe's
wife
dedicated part of her speech about how
she would never compliment him and bring
him down to earth like
again ugh why
would you want to be in a relationship
where you're in charge of bringing
somebody down to earth
because kobe was in that bill gates
level
and we won't go any further about that
but uh
i don't i it was it seems like she
wanted to live
in a world of michelle obama said that
about barack on 60 minutes
disgusted me when she said it um my job
is to bring him down to
bring him back down to earth what a
horrible job
it's a horrible so you're a full-time
hater
that's really funny that's basically
what what she said
i have a joke uh that i would never work
but women only say nice stuff about
their husband if he gets assassinated
and until then it's just like nate's
fine it's fine oh this idiot
just like again and i don't think guys
are in any way good partners to women
either so um
i agree with you that you should be i
think it's at a certain point what's the
number
though the problem is that billionaire
single guys are i mean i see them on
dating apps
so what are you doing you know it's like
they also want these celebrity guys
they also want some part of this
traditional
structure too the guys the guys that
don't
single famous and
wealthy yeah but i because it's never it
why are you coming to the thing that you
feel entrapped in the age of me too
i don't think they're looking for
marriage between you and me uh
i don't think anybody i don't think
they're getting on the app to be like i
gotta marry them
abroad i just think they're
coming to date not famous people yeah
4a who are then who else i'm going to
date no i'm just saying they're coming
on an
app to date women your traditional
structure
you could just [ __ ] you could [ __ ] they
could [ __ ] two girls a day they don't
need to go on an app
uh there is no app for that by the way
they're on riot to [ __ ] two girls a day
uh was ben affleck if someone just like
if you really want a disconnected
if he could yeah yeah but i i i find it
hard to not to
if you want to [ __ ] two girls a day i
mean those aren't that's not like a fun
girl you hang out with
that's a call girl yeah that's what
castro has that's what casual hats so
if you want that you can get that you
don't need to
go to raya for that and go oh she un
followed me let me go find her guys
would like to do it
with human women sure on
in a way that they want which is
dating as many women as i can possibly
date
with as few attachments as possible
guys are guys are real uh hypocrites
because
guys want girls to want them
go when a g or or guys want girls to
miss them think about that yeah have
those organic have
all that all the [ __ ] that we're like
you need to chill out right
we also if it's not there it's like oh
if it's transactional if it's as
transactional as
they want it in their mind like i don't
know strings of tests
there's going to be something they yearn
for there's going to be something
missing you know yeah
they want it both ways we figured it out
you guys like
you got to have you built marry somebody
start a foundation
and have sex with two call girls a day
good luck prenup hello lawyer hello
law it's neil i got an idea
to put in the prenup um
so yeah there's uh
i enjoyed it i enjoyed building i enjoy
watching bill gates
it's uh crumble not crumble i just enjoy
watching it like it's everyone
it is every guy in the world is like
this there's no
even that [ __ ] nerd who has no
business
asking a woman for anything
is saying i'm i'm trying to [ __ ] it yeah
it doesn't matter the power level
doesn't matter the
the banking thing does not [ __ ]
matter you guys are animals
we just want it's why we're here the
indomitable spirit
of horny men
um anyhow you know it's interesting
there was a
there was an election post-mortem about
the um
who what actually happened in the
election
in terms of demographically and there's
a lot of surprises not a lot of
surprises
scroll down well um most diverse
election ever
it was on catalyst how do they know what
race someone is
or ethnicity because they fill it out
you fill it up on your thing i think
he's the other
tell me about it um
uh you may well that's why there's like
non
latino non there's all kinds of weird
categories elektra was 72 percent
white which is so crazy it's you just
forget how many white people are in
america
you really do and yeah they don't know
they don't realize
how much of a majority they have in this
country because the asians are breathing
down our necks
um can't get up can't get any space out
here
uh 72 white that's the elector those are
the people that voted right
um it was that 72 percent white compared
to 74
white in 2016 and 77 white in 2008.
so it's we're we are following we are
part three we are being replaced
we are make no mistake um
the college degree thing is where the
buying ticket benefited from a diverse
set of supporters 39
of their coalition were voters of color
and the remaining 61
were split fairly even between white
voters with
and without a college degree um
that's that i could look at this [ __ ]
all day yeah
um the trump pence ticket was more
homogeneous with nearly 60 of their
votes coming from
non-white i'm sorry from white
non-college voters
okay yeah that makes sense 60 of their
votes came from
not from white non-non-voters um
i want to do an accent right now do you
think it's from the north or the south
um republicans the
latino voters continue to favor
democrats
but republicans did a little better um
61 percent voted for biden
and that's down from it's kind of
confusing but it's
a little down keep going black vote
turnout
increased substantially resulting in
significant gains for democrats
uh despite a modest overall drop in
democratic support levels
so more black people voted but more
black people voted uh
republican than than they did last night
seven percent more i believe
three percent i'm sorry three percent
three percent more
swung toward trump so it's a net gain
right because it's like a three percent
uh it's probably
total nine percent uh asian american
pacific islanders
we're good for democrats urban rural
voting
divide con continues to be immensely
important
suburbs growing more democratic and more
racially diverse
women remain critical to democrats young
voters
this is a crazy one millennials and gen
z now account for 31 percent of voters
yay i like them i love gen z i like gen
z
um melania sucker sucker from the back
obviously
uh new voters made a big difference
in sun belt swing states
um 29 were new
and there's still millions of non-voters
who i mean there's so many people that
don't vote it's
kind of yeah because the person is
stupid
why would i wear a mask you don't gotta
vote
the math thing is like when people have
stickers on and you're the i voted
stickers and you're like
yeah it's not patting yourself on the
back are you safe
um that's the mask uh condescension
um increase in votes by race the thing
that was in here the white
people move white men moved from trump
to bud
like seven percent which what made all
oh
thank you we did it again white men
hahaha
science and now this actually was the
egyptians who made science yes
anyhow insurrection remember january 6
do i do i might [ __ ] i got hit in
there like a punch in the face like a
pizza
uh so this guy said
that they were just regular tourists oh
yeah most of the people there were
tourists yeah
most people were there were taurus and
he said i should know
i was one of the people barricading the
door from the tourists
you know how tourists get i can't tell
you how many times i
barricaded doors from tourists
at like the comedy store they'll be
one of them will jump in a woman she'll
get shot
like tourists you know you know like
tourists well
they'll take a thing they'll take an uh
uh
ashtray and use that to break the giant
window
like a tourist does this guy actually um
was in a bank one time and a bunch of
robbers came in and he goes oh they must
be
scouting a location these are location
scouters
here to see if they can film something
in the bank and then there was a
shootout
and he said oh now they're doing a
ballistics test
so i could go on with these but i think
that's enough for now
uh it reminds me of an old joke from
david tell
which is uh he a guy said i didn't stab
him he fell on my knife right and let's
just say that night
he backed into a couple of dicks
now um yeah these
peop the
like i don't get the line the
it's i hate to use this word but the gas
lighting
i you don't i don't like the word gas
lighting i think is used improperly and
it's just
like annoying buzz word
um but this feels like gaslighting it's
like no
that didn't happen yeah no they were
tourists
what no they were it was fine i'm like
it has to be beneficial in some way
they're just gonna lie because
telling the truth will get them liz
cheney'd
so they have to lie that's a very clear
thing
if you don't lie you are going to lose
your power
and you'll get primaried and and and so
they all have to
so people who watch
own and fox and all that [ __ ] fox news
are it's the skinny mirror it's it's
it doesn't even matter what these guys
do all they have to do is
be on tv saying something it
truly does not matter how they voted
it's
what are you saying on the tv show that
these people are watching
right that's it it's a tv they don't
even really
care if they see because how often does
the government do something
that affects you so if it's
rare as far as i'm concerned and so if
some but i
do i am watching this tv show where the
other side
are baby eaters or whatever and this is
a
this is a primal battle
and so and this guy's on our side and
he's lying on tv
they're taking credit for [ __ ] they
voted against right like they just have
to go
on it's about the tv show it does not
matter how they vote it
i truly believe it does not liz cheney
voted with trump 94 percent of time it
doesn't
that's the thing she went on the tv show
and said the wrong thing
so you're gone and it doesn't seem like
republicans would go against this kind
of like basically with the gop the gop
sticking by trump so any republicans who
go against him
are becoming unpopular they're not only
gonna they're on they're worse than
unpopular they're
done well they're done but i feel like
mitt romney is
right well he can because his his his
status so they were never for trump
so they they were they were the only
they almost voted against them
yeah in the first election they were
like he barely won utah if at all
right um so but there are a lot of
people who
they're [ __ ] they frank luntz was on
somebody's show frank luntz the guy with
the toupee and that who's the
the um the uh focus group
guy yeah
and he said you in order to win
local elections house elections you
have to be pro-trump but in order to win
a national election you you cannot beat
pro-trump
it's so weird so they have whoever run
if trump doesn't run
for president they're the the primary is
going to be spent
saying how much they love them and then
the
the main election will be spent it's
going like you know
it's there we see eye to eye on most
things
right but i gotta say and they'll just
spin it to where
they'll just distance himself from i'm
my own president
this is not president trump too this is
it's just no one's going out like
usually when you go against the bad guy
quote unquote you
end up looking a bit more heroic
there and there's no i mean it's just
like there's no one to applaud her
because you voted with trump so on the
left it's like
i don't have much sympathy for liz
cheney yeah and on the right
you went against the order yep so
so there's no benefit this is where you
just have to be a psycho
so sketch writing and sketch writing you
got it
and if you're gonna run for any of this
[ __ ] you gotta
if you wanna have ethics ethics now
are bad for business i mean for the most
part of course you can pre
only if that's your whole thing right
more ethical and we like to recycle um
anyhow so the that's pretty great
and then the pipeline did you understand
the pipeline thing i understood it
so basically we've been
susceptible like american critical
resources have been susceptible to
they would i think they thought like
state-backed
political attacks but now there's
a lot of um hackers that are just
for-profit
and and some are going to be working for
the state also i think
it's like yeah they're not but it's just
more
just like give us money where we'll do
this
as opposed to just [ __ ] up your your
situation so this one was a for profit
for profit one
and that that's the reason why gas is
expensive
i wouldn't know i know a little
electricity
but it's wild that it just feels like a
90s action [ __ ] like some
i don't know exactly yeah
uh it is attacked the pipeline yeah and
it's like
no gas shortage crazy people filling up
gas with
plastic bags for some reason so
i don't i heard bill gates was out
ejaculating in gas tanks
that's the guy needs to ejaculate and
he's gonna any hole he can get to
he will use so and it was uh
it was it was it was leaded where you
know
ejaculation was had lead in it so
and it was diesel which i don't
understand these rich people
really do have it different you know
what i thought though
about this story is it's just a pipe
that brings it's so much more it's less
complicated than you think
it's a pipeline where the
gasoline is going five miles an hour
yeah i mean when you really think about
most things it's
it's the so basic you would think you
know end of the world movies
where they have these screens up and the
like war room is so
technological and technologically
advanced
and then you're using like pieces of
wood like the old subway
like taking of the pelham one two three
yeah and then when you look at it it's
like
oh it's just a pipe yep it's a hole it's
a tube
and then it kind of runs downhill yeah
they do sometimes we have to pump it up
then it gets to the east coast
what's a what what's a dam it's just we
put a giant wall up uh
so water can't get through
what is hydroelectric the wall we put a
rotor in and then by the way this is a
side note that i've been meaning to get
to thank you for bringing it up you're
welcome
i think
wind power turbines are cool-looking
remember how trump would be like they're
an eyesore i think they just look like
art to me they look like giant
insulators they're scary kind of
when you go up close yeah when you go
close they're very like serious
um but those i've never seen a picture
of
wind turbines have been like ugh they
look
cool as [ __ ] that's one of those things
where they go they're loud and they're
an eyesore i don't they look cool
they're not loud
well that was trump's thing it's like
you can't hear they give cancer
i yeah we me and my friend went on a
road trip and we went to
the the wind farm next to palm springs
and it was it was cool it honestly there
was some it was really
interesting to be that close to it but
there's a lot of broken ones
yeah yeah so yeah um
look it's not perfect it's not it's not
it's not a perfect system
um but it's pretty cool i didn't say the
and they
never are broken and they're
cool looking and they've never once have
they ever
broken wind turbines i'm neil brennan
um so just stop using gas if you can't
just get an electric car
like me and they'll be incentive soon
and it'll be the only kind of car you
can really get at
in california yeah no if you look at the
long term everywhere in america like
you're just not there's not gonna be
a thing which is i'm very excited about
but there are dumb guys who are like i
just need that
they're not even dumb it's some of my
favorite people in the world
uh like i need the roar of the
interesting idiot
how about your phone do you need a gang
gang gang like nah i can't
just electricity doesn't do it for me um
anyhow kobe got in doctor the hall of
fame
he did i now i'm not a sports
a basketball gal uh-huh but i
thought he would have already been there
uh they have a thing where the
it's a you have to not be active for a
certain amount of years oh and then you
qualify yeah
okay um did you watch
i did watch it and regretted it why
because uh tim duncan's speech i liked
and but that was about
it in terms of the speech i liked i
don't want to get into the ones i didn't
like
i will say listening to vanessa's speech
there's a whole there's a whole thing
about her kobe's parents
and she like mentioned like i invited
them
she there was like a whole thing where i
was like this is damage control
and then i saw today that they weren't
invited and
it's just you i don't know i said this
on here but
family you know when they're like it's a
it's a tv show it's a family drama
you can't even do a show about actual
family drama
no because it's so dark
and so painful right
that you can't even cover it most of it
you can't you literally
can't cover it because you know what i
you know why else it wouldn't be a good
show
because it never gets resolved right
it just do you like six decades two
decades
three days i haven't watched it but i
that's not that's
awesome that's an office power thing
that's like that you can plot that you
can't plot
but something they were going to sell
kofi
kobe's trophies at one point because
they
it was like and part of it was kind of
like some funny mom [ __ ] where
he wouldn't take he was keeping trophies
there and he wouldn't take him
and then the mom was like i'm i'm
auctioning them off
did she uh they worked something out
but but um
you can't you can't with the families
right
literally cannot plot it because it's
too
too crazy there's tension was there
always tension between coving's kobe and
his family
uh right his parents seem it seems like
they
i don't know what they look like so that
seems bad
you know what i mean like i don't even
have i mean i have i've seen videos of
the dad but i've never
seen like i don't know
didn't know that's what his dad looked
like at all like at all
didn't know that looks like an i.t guy
he does um oh there he is all right so
maybe they were around more than i just
didn't know or they didn't want press or
whatever
i just thought that there was a weird
thing with his dad and they didn't talk
for a long time and then
oh yeah i mean finances oh there we go
yeah challenges of mixing blood with
business as well as anger resentment and
jealousy that made
that this may lead to oh yeah right
there right there you go you know how
many
examples are in that not resolvable
present uh
resentment and jealousy yeah there's a
hundred stories yes
how much money do you how much
the stories i've heard from just like
people i know that are like
normal rich with family and
but this is you can't you just not
solvable it's not even solid you can't
plot it you can't even talk about it
it's too upsetting most family problems
are too upsetting to even talk about
right and then when you do a lot of them
from the
outside perspective don't seem that big
of a deal
you weren't [ __ ] there you don't you
didn't know her
tone yeah that's it's
uh it's also you can't explain
the whole entirety of the relationship
and you need it kind of
that's why siblings are good to vent to
about mom or about yeah about mom dad
yeah of course but they don't always
agree
oh no they definitely don't sometimes
they make it worse yeah and sometimes
they might they might leak it
oh yeah the ladies there's a lot of
things that can go wrong
there's a yeah press leak yep little
press leak
little little bill gates's melinda gates
melinda french gates that's what she
she uh that that's her old name so now
she's
in every article it's melinda french
gates which if you were so french
let your husband [ __ ] on the side you
know what i mean lady
you know what i mean neil that one was
perfect
there was a good one and a bad one at
the same time i said
i want to [ __ ] her i want to focus
um do you see this story what anybody
see this anyways
did anybody say the story i gotta
remember the name of this i know did you
see
soya look up soya motorcycle will
it's a fun one so yeah
oh i like you it was it's a female biker
who started posting on on tick tock and
ig
was not a fema uh woman it was a
guy who was just himself
show his uh uh
i think people are mad i don't
he this guy's [ __ ] really good at
face tune
oh she's so cute but then people
started but so then so i'm we're just
looking at pictures and not saying
what's happening i'm not saying
all right so this guy
was retired and
kids are adults it's only 50. so
um the so he started just riding
he's like a big motorcycle he's got like
eight motorcycles or something riding
around
no followers on any platform and was
like
this is he posted one thing it was like
sad got like eight
likes or followers and so then he just
started face tuning himself
into a beautiful woman and uh
started getting a lot of traction as a
hot woman who's into motorcycles so
guys are like oh this is you're perfect
and and then eventually he said like
hey he keep he gave up the ghost as it
were
and came forward and then people were
like i still like you
oh that's lovely i is it
well it he gave it up on his own it's
not like he's yeah no i get it no i'm
not saying it like he
but i'm just wondering
for all the talk of
what of um
i this is the that joke i have done
about
how people don't like writers
yeah they if the cast of friends was
downstairs or the
writers from friends were downstairs
it's a very different
level of aggression getting downstairs
i like writers i remember my friend went
to afi
and i remember this one year he invited
me to all the
parties and i also watched the award
show parties
no just the afi like uh the faculty
like they're just christmas parties and
then i went to some of my
actor friends who were on tv shows like
active actor friend parties
and we did just we hit up a bunch of
parties this one weekend
and the writer parties were infinitely
more fun
interesting i wouldn't say that they're
more i don't know writers to be more fun
than
actors yeah well they just felt
i'd say more interesting obviously more
engaging conversational they just felt
looser and not performative and not
yeah there wasn't a show yeah i don't
know might get canceled
but whatever let's have a shot like
everything was really casual
yeah and the other ones were very like
oh my god
welcome oh my god so tell me about that
like a lot more [ __ ] talk yeah at
one than the other
so so they claim
i mean i guess it's cute that this old
older guy wanted
the context like liked yeah so then and
also their [ __ ] and they're like
i was only in this for the face the
smooth face
and the idea of my my prediction is you
just lose this follower
just lose the followers steadily yeah
it's like just steadily over time you
can't leave immediately
no but like i don't know it's like when
a girl or
a guy if you're talking to a girl or a
guy and they say they have a boyfriend
or girlfriend you're just like you can't
go like
time's up so you have to be like yeah
interesting so one more question
then i'm gonna pretend that i what
that's
not totally life-changing information
for me
and then i'll get out of here
that happened i was like a few times on
when i was on dating apps the
chatting let's grab a drink i do i
always do a deep dive if i can find it
just to make sure
every time like are you in a
relationship
yeah but it's an open thing like i'm
allowed to like
it's like it's opening that i saw an
opening to cheat on her and i took it
i'm like yeah i
i don't know i feel un like close-minded
saying
well i'm not gonna [ __ ] go on a date
with you if you have a girlfriend
yeah so you have to do the slow
you oh you won't say no you won't just
say that's a
red line for me i do say no
but it's very hard for me i feel
extremely
uh i feel like i'm going against the
what
it's his choice it's not my problem it's
not i'm not sure
yeah he said it's open open my i don't
know i feel like these days you have to
be open-minded about
all forms of relationships and
when i'm not black and white i'll never
be open about that
neil loves the swirl um
yeah you know like but you know what's a
good thing to think of
in those situations is if i say that
that's a red line for me
and end this uh
it'll be awkward and then in 90 seconds
it will be my life will be better that's
good i'm going to remember that because
i literally
have 90 seconds of discomfort and then
it's over just start a clock
literally get a stopwatch and go boop
start it and go that's a red line for me
nice meeting you
thumbs up emoji and then whatever they
say
now can i accuse you of something please
liking the attention of what a guy
uh guy being interested in you having a
girlfriend
then you have a choice to make which is
like do i keep accepting this attention
and or if i draw a red line no more
attention
no no no i don't at me all
i think it's kind of weird so it made me
uncomfortable
open relationships yeah so i wasn't like
ooh i didn't want his attention anymore
he made me uncomfortable oh then
the red line at 90 says start the clock
i'm going to call i'm just going to text
you
red line i mean i
um oh this is a useless observation you
ready
[Music]
last one's um funny i don't you may have
no idea what i'm talking about okay
i don't like when they
someone's very old in show business
and they kind of trot them out
and it's the same way they treat little
kids
and there's something about it that just
bums me out
so deeply like the the most recent one
was uh norman
well look up dick van dyke because dick
van dyke there's like a picture i'm like
still on some like whoop-dee-doo [ __ ]
and he's it was in the washington post i
believe
but just this like
yeah there you go top left but like why
boy look at me
[ __ ] jovial yeah he's like in a
in a chair is there's like a thing
someone
threw out a chair on the street yeah can
you and he's got a cane and he's kind of
like
on some whoop-dee-doo [ __ ] there's no
other way to put it
ejaculate whoop-dee-doo [ __ ] and i don't
like it the guy from he just died this
week he was in
uh train wreck he was in a train wreck
and died no he was in
the movie train wreck his name's norman
something norman lloyd yes
but the pictures of him if you look at
norman lloyd
images even those are a bit like
that's actually old man that's cool
that's old man with gravitas
some of them are like well
like a little dancy i don't i can't
explain the one with the tennis racket
you ain't it's like it's like what you
do to a dog or a little kid
it's wrong it's like wrong of
the press people
to i don't it's something it's just
wrong like johnny carson did it
perfectly right
goodbye you'll never see me again right
and there was
one photo of him from like a long
telephoto lens where he was just
someone introduced he's just [ __ ] on
and by himself on a boat it's a bad
picture
but he didn't want it out there that's
actually not a bad picture
he looks good there was one where he
kind of gained weight and he just looked
like infirmed
and i'm not saying it like hey get out
of here would you get lost with your
gross aging
but i don't like when they per it's
i don't there's something like old
minstrelly about it yeah
and also you don't want that to happen
to you
yeah yeah it he looks like
it's like weekend at bernie's kind of
yeah where they're prop it's like he
looks like a stuffed
like he's been taxidermied what are you
going to do
when you're older and people want to
write
or you know you're in the entertainment
no thanks
because at a certain point what do you
what are you getting new fans what do
you do
like yeah there's a i'm not people know
about me
if you're that level of famous people
know about you and
i won't even get into some of morgan
freeman's choices
like where he's on people's albums now
you're like no
man like i like that voiceover for dave
he's on like oh yeah that's good for
dave
he's on the um album 21 savage that's
exactly right he's on 21 savage's album
i don't know man oh i just don't think i
would have
done it i wouldn't have advised him to
do it
i don't know i i don't like that he does
discovery channel [ __ ]
there's just certain [ __ ] that like nah
man you know you're james earl jones
right like just you do cnn and you
and and simba uh you december cnn
and and the come to america right
that's your life you don't you don't
want any more james jones
he died when did he die he died didn't
he
james jones died no he didn't
the hell neil no i'm telling you i'm
gonna murder him
okay it was like he died well no
he was in a movie maybe he just wasn't
he in it was
he was very sick when they were filming
i know that oh that's awful no
please um
so something to think he dies around be
very upset just be
like regal is what i'm saying and not
let people
decline to clown you like hold this
tennis racket
as if you could play tennis
[ __ ] you anyhow
neil's a old people defender i love it
you like you like documentaries hey dog
you like documentary
um do you watch crime in the century no
i didn't but i'm
very excited yeah uh like that was when
i got
excited it's good alex give me clean
laid out well
clever editing and the story is so
tell the people it's about um
it's about merck and i think it's mark
actually it's not it's the uh sackler
family uh
who owned the company that sold um
oxygen yeah and
is it episodic there's it's two parts so
i only know i'm two so um so it's
just atrocious it made me think of
what it would have been probably a funny
sketch
if in order to get away with selling
drugs you just have to have a
pharmacy jacket but if there were just
guys selling crack wearing
pharmaceutical
wearing the pharmacist jackets like on
the corner
um it's just so awful i heard they say
they call them pill billies yeah pill
billy's is the big one that's funny yeah
that's a good one i do love a good pun
yes uh pill bellies was
uh there was also
yeah some there was another one but um
just crime
lying under oath criminals
and then politicians bought off
to not legislate it or not prosecute
them
or and they just got away with it
billions of dollars they're now getting
sued but they're
even the suit that they're that the
sacklers are getting hit with now is
like
they're gonna be fine they made billions
of dollars yeah
their wives are gonna let them [ __ ] on
the side that's how well they did with
this drug
but it also shows you like what guys
will go to
to just get a bunch of money
just lying and killing people yeah
killing people
they the the hack on on it on on
oxycontin was
smash it because it's it was long time
release
and and so there's a coating on the pill
right smash it the coating is gone you
can get
a giant dose of an amazing
opiate why would anyone not do that
and then part two is about fentanyl
and um which is a thousand times more
powerful than morphine
damn it's crazy so 500 000 people have
died from that in the last 20 years
including prince and like right people
that you value
people that people value not just pill
bills not just pill billies
um do you think i know her your your
friend
that wrote the book about doing drugs
and stuff but
do they talk about if the is it that we
have something in us that gets addicted
to the numbing of it or are they
you know like is it is it chemically
addictive a lot of people start with
actual pain
and then they're just addicted there's a
story of a woman
there's photographs of her i mean
remember i forgot a lot of these
pictures but
like they were the national story where
there'll be two parents passed out in
the front seat
yeah and and that's
i don't know if that's fentanyl or oxy
but there's a woman who they follow
who her husband would take pictures of
her she would just like
pass out from
overdosing but not dying right and it's
just so
grim and the doctor they focus on one
doctor who
a hundred people died in his care
um and it's not nothing happened to him
just [ __ ] crazy yeah it's so great um
so
uh that's really good crime of the
century okay i highly advise it i didn't
blow anything
hit it well
[Music]
oh yeah we got a we got some songs we
got um
a new theme song which is kind of
i don't even know how to describe it's a
little acoustic-y or something or it's
like very
heart heartfelt
[Music]
you know what i realized great vocals
take the vocals
replace the piano the piano doesn't
quite to me
doesn't get there that's why it's going
to be a no for me dog no i'm kidding
um no it's i love it of course yeah it's
great
uh i see if we can do something with the
piano
wha what would you do i don't know
something okay
something something don't know listen to
me in levine's
music podcast we'll talk all about it oh
great
um do we have any anybody else a new
chapel
story song great he edited uh i think
it's a different
oh a different chappelle story okay a
dave chappelle story by neil
that's pretty good great beautiful thank
you
thank you sir who was that luis at louis
espinoza
oh no louis espinoza was the song and
[Music]
justin smith justin smith thank you
justin smith
justin louis espinoza
um any anybody else oh now we have audio
yeah and video set keep sending in the
audio they're better and video
goodbye you've got mail this is rocco
your bipolar correspondent
yay uh is directed by the spirit padre
i tried holotropic breathing last night
for about five minutes
and it was weird um
it kind of felt like i was like
waterboarding myself or something it
wasn't
a pleasant experience but i gather that
uh ayahuasca is not really supposed to
be
uh fun for anybody it's about personal
growth
um i don't i did it for like i said
about five minutes uh
if i'd done it for longer maybe i would
have
seen the face of the infinite or touched
the hand of the cosmos
and uh maybe that would long term lead
me
to um developing some sort of a sense of
equipoise about the nature of mortality
uh as it is i think i will just take
your word for it
say what you want about bipolar people
they're almost universally intelligent
that guy's a smart dude um it's not a
five minute thing
it's like a half hour minimum but i
don't but also
please be careful it's just a thing i
heard about i did it once
um there are classes and stuff you can
do but please don't hurt yourself
the podcast is great right we uh are not
liable for anything please don't do
anything
because i heard of it right right the
good thing is
i feel like deep breathing is pretty
harmless
it's not deep breathing it's
hyperventilating oh it's like
yeah by design and you just do it for a
long time
and then you go you it [ __ ] with your
chemicals and
that's what happens don't do it yeah so
you can do it people do it and
really like it breath works yeah but
it's
not the same thing as the oh cause i
said breath work and you're like yeah
this is breathing
not exactly it like it is technically
breath work
but it's not breath work as it's
understood holotropic breathing is its
own
thing yeah interesting okay um
have you done breath work well i was
breathing in my stomach this week
i'm i'm redesigning my walk
i was wearing knee pads for you guys no
but
my legs are too straight general
generally it's funny the guy's like you
got to change this so i've been
i got knee pain i've been i don't
twist my hips enough wait well don't
it's very
you should follow my motorcycle blog um
no it's i don't i it you'll see maybe
there's no i'm gonna unveil it
uh but i just i don't bend my knees
i don't have good balance because i
don't bend my knees enough
so not like i'm off balance you're like
a tin man but i can
yeah but i can be i can be better i
don't know what you look like when you
walk
like how i think about it now you're
going to be like walk again walk
do it come over walk i want to hear it
um
yeah so i'm always rebuilding everything
all the time
um anything goodbye you've got mail hey
neil and
billy blinks for all those tybo fans
tuesday listener thursday watcher um
congress continues to spend showing the
dollars on defense
and some of that money seems severely
mismanaged
so uh if you could break off a piece of
that budget
what would you do with it i think it'd
be really cool to support
uh government research you know we got
the internet
uh helped up with the code vaccine it
looks like we might get a hiv vaccine
out of it
so how neal phil what does banks think
what should we do with
government uh my tax payer dollar
mostly goes to military or
disproportionately
uh what should it go to the arts
something
um the
jazz uh no it should go to uh
it should go to education and poverty
and um that's kind of all i would want
yeah
poverty and climate yeah
that's it nailed it yeah not like
i like how republicans think they won't
benefit from any of this
it's like the wave isn't going to go oh
you're repub the giant wave that's going
to come right
or they're like socialism but then they
go to countries and vacation in
countries where
saying social security medicare that's
all you need to say okay
absolute socialism um the military
anything else
goodbye you've got me neil and banks i'm
reluctantly sending this audio message
because she said you
prefer audio messages yes i
am reaching out about the panic attacks
you mentioned
i had a period of about three years
where i suffered from panic attacks
and the method i came up with to deal
with them was called
a b c d i'll never remember that
keep going a awareness of your thoughts
she does her own music anxieties are
rolling in your brain
can you let them go or at least consider
they might be [ __ ]
b breathe slowly
and deliberately c calm your body
search for any parts that might be tense
and relax them
d don't draw in others
telling other people you are freaking
out tends to make them freak out
and just exacerbate things try to leave
others out of it unless it's a true
emergency
i hope it helps someone else out there i
kill the music
i actually used to keep it um in my
wallet on a slip of paper as a reminder
this is hard to remember thanks to
everyone i'm a saturday listener
you guys were my treat for making it
through another week of coronavirus
thanks a lot um i like her
i like her production i love that she
will she she she
brings her own keyboard by okay um
yeah i don't mind uh i don't mine are
not about
doubt i don't think my panic attacks i'm
not like you're you have no right to
just some i get an adrenaline i get a
an adrenaline surge and my body's not so
you don't have racing thoughts
uh no i just can't really breathe
which is hard when you part one of the
key things to talking is
uh you have to inhale yeah so i can't
really breathe but i can
and then i can't really remember that
what i'm supposed to say because i'm
because i'm thinking about can you just
like i don't know
has i i'm gonna reapproach it but i
it's i don't think it's because
i don't uh my thoughts aren't racing
like i'm gonna
it's just it's just this thing
it's basically keyboard but it's
like it just and it kind of overwhelms
you and i don't know when it's going to
happen
and how long does it generally last 20
seconds and then so it's like
then it's done what do you do are you
like then i'm fine i'm like where am i
who are you momento uh the no i'm
fine i just it's when i'm speaking when
i'm there to speak
um and you don't know when that's gonna
happen
not really new pl new stages is
is one of the things or plays i haven't
been in a while like
the improv i kind of had one new stages
yeah so it's a form of stage fright
not exactly because it's not state it's
not
stage fright is any state like this is a
new environment
like some chris goes dave doesn't do
sound check
chris does because he wants to know what
the
whenever i'm on a new stage i think i'm
going to fall off
because i'm like i don't know i'm like
the kelsey grammer falling off the stage
i'm truly afraid i'm gonna fall and rock
i think is too
so i have to go like look at it
to know where the parameters are that's
because i'm afraid i'm going to
go oh um could have shown it don't worry
about it well
um so goodbye
you've got mayo uh yeah so those are all
the audios no there's a couple more oh
great
thank you for all the audio questions
guys yes hey detectives jimmy mcnealty
and
binx moreland pardon the shitty wire pun
i have a question for neil you say you
know what happens
after you die because of insight you've
gained through plant medicine
i'd like to know what makes you so
certain in the objective reality of your
experiences
and how that's different from faith
which you used to [ __ ] on a lot
i'm not casting doubt on what you
learned i just want to know how you
logically justify your new profound
belief system
it's probably clear i've never done
ayahuasca and there's something i can't
understand until i've done it but how
could you explain it
all right thanks for the great podcast i
love
everyone sounds hostile even and then
they're like love what you guys do
really why are you mad i would have
guessed you were mad at me
uh i didn't say i know what happens when
you die
i said i i
get the i i have a different conception
of it now
that i and the reason i think it's true
is because
uh it was not told it
was just kind of if you accept that
there's a universal beam i'm such a
maniac
okay uh if you accept that there's a
universal beam then you go yeah i'm just
gonna go
into the beam i don't know of course i
don't know what's gonna happen
and uh it it sounds like faith
uh it because it is
i was an atheist and now i'm not that
anymore
um and
the faith part it i guess it's faith but
i
i tie all that [ __ ] up in the crosses
and
right rosary beads and all that [ __ ]
so i don't it's more like uh
i think that's what's gonna happen but
i'm not
i yeah i don't that's what it seems like
it's going to happen worse before it
seemed like nothing was going to happen
right now it seems like something's
going on i watch a show called
i survived the on and back i'm not
suggesting they use that little kid
there's a little kid who like there was
a book where he said he and then it
turned out to not be true oh that's a
heaven is real
yeah that's what that movie is based on
uh
because he says heaven is real nobody
and i survived beyond and backs
talks about heaven there's one there's a
new one on netflix apparently like
cheating death or something
oh really yeah um they yeah and all the
stories are really
kind of similar like their
bodies dying in their their spirits
leaving them and
it's all james earl jones go ahead
this he should do that i'm glad he did
that i'm glad he did i survived
die anyways basically
if you listen to a lot of them there's
it's similar enough
where i don't know when i did ayahuasca
it all feels similar yeah then
more similar than how what religion
tells you is gonna happen yeah so
that's kind of i take those religion
like i said is the perversion of
ayahuasca or it's that's what
i that's what i kind of think religion
is a per
is everything a provision of everyone's
mostly okay i i but i actually believe
that because it's like a game of
telephone where you're like
what yeah you guys aren't absolutely
wrong
but like right what what
mad at who hell what are you talking
about so
anyhow um
so yeah so drop the hostility next time
goodbye
you've got to hello neil and blink 182.
bink182 i've been following more
comedians on instagram this past year
and a lot of them post 10 to 20 stories
every single day
along with many traditional photo posts
although these people
have awesome and unique personalities i
can't help but get fatigued and unfollow
them after a few weeks
heck even accounts accounts that post
once a day
get annoying eventually while it is
important to have social media presence
for
public figures why do you think so many
comedians and other people in the
entertainment industry
are toned up to the amount of content
that is palatable
neil you've found a good balance of
posts a few days a week
um and that keeps you presents
with that keeps your presence more fresh
than many of your contemporaries
and bianca you're smoking hot photos a
few times a month
is a perfect amount to keep us saying
have mercy in a jessie katzopoulos voice
no you have to say it
i only know it from the hulu commercial
i i've never seen it on the official
show nope
what do your best version have mercy no
no
i'm not doing a [ __ ] what am i an old
one of my norman lloyd
over here do a thing tennis racket
yourself
go grab your tennis bag yeah good now
what show us it's a talent show all of a
sudden
um i don't know what the right amount is
i don't we're doing we're doing pretty
good thank anyone
to him but i think that the more
you post i think it affects the
algorithm
where you can get more i think you just
get more followers that way yeah
i don't my jokes are in two categories
they either work or they
don't i'm not gonna sell it with charm
i'm not that cute i'm not gonna try to
make like
sexy ones i'm just never gonna
so if i post something i'm it's
probably funny now having said that
sorry to eat some places in the middle
um real quick i did i need to put it
real quick
let me knock this [ __ ] on real quick
while i'm saying when i'm talking about
the inmate
um and so i don't know
and i don't i also don't know why people
follow me or unfollow me i have no
[ __ ] idea
follow me i understand the post you made
out you netted
one person yeah in a week
in a week of of instagram i lost 700
and gained 701 for
for like whatever's supposed to work for
people does not work for me
like i remember dalia going like just
post the more you post them and i was
like
i just don't that's not going to work
for me it's just not going to work for
me
and sure enough you're going to be the
outlier yeah
whatever it is i i'm not going to do it
it will not
favor me doing things like the classic
will not work will not work
your thoughts on frequency of posting
uh it depends you know a lot of times i
want to post and i'm like
no one cares like that happens to me a
lot
like no one cares about my opinion
uh when i just don't think that and i
post it and then
everyone's like yay i've never had a not
doing well thing
it's that i don't like being annoying
i guess i don't like being annoying with
me and my opinion and my
ev whatever is banky there's something
about
like there's the amount of times i write
something rude and like
yeah just that's not nice like i don't
have i don't yeah
oh you don't get into the sport fighting
none of
the social media just doesn't i don't
have
i'm not bonded to it doesn't it doesn't
bait me in i don't
go for the bait yeah so even if the like
you know
twitter karate the
complimentary you know even all of that
i mean i can post sexy photos i have a
bazillion sexy photos
i just okay that must be nice
um even the complimentary
uh feedback i get from like a nice photo
a nice photo doesn't
make me want to post more well it's
gross
it's like it's so nice no that's not
gross necessarily i guess it's gross
wanting it
one yes exactly or if somebody says
something on
line you know i watch my trash tv and i
follow the people
secretly and sometimes they do things i
don't like and i want to
scold them but i'm like interesting
don't do that i just i don't have the
i never take the bait well yeah i people
yell at me
i was writing a thing this week where it
was like
the internet is basically you go
it's like um a store you go to to get
batteries and then yeah
someone bumps you and next thing you
know you're in a [ __ ] melee
you but you went there just to get the
score of the game
right and then you're [ __ ] like [ __ ]
i'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] you
and then there's the checkout line with
a bunch of [ __ ] you don't need and
you're like
it's just not worth anything but keith
stanfield
had a good week on social media i did
see that
um it's all so active right but it's all
the if you're famous
any post that isn't
promotional i mean they're all
promotional but some of them are just
a deposition it's just a deposition
for a trial that hasn't happened yet
you're just every just your [ __ ]
opinion
right okay this is gonna be so you're
this is all on the record also
there's get off instagram what's the
problem right because lakeith was doing
stuff like going on chat rooms and
moaning
i'm like come on man oh yeah so yeah
he needed a break goodbye hi
uh i have a this is a good question i
have a professional question i'm a white
woman who has worked at my company for
over
10 years over the past few years i'd
become bored in my job and last summer i
started looking for a new one
couldn't find one applied to around 30
places and never got an interview
luckily
i was eventually assigned to a new
project at my current company
my dream project the project is a large
one that requires two people to manage
because the company is mostly white men
and we were in the throes of an
increased national awareness around
racial inequity a lot of people
including myself pushed to hire
a non-white person from outside they
ended up hiring a black woman
we are several months into co-working
the project and the new hire
is all caps terrible she doesn't have
the needed experience she doesn't
like to work hard and she has major
issues with depression and anxiety
um that greatly affects her ability to
do her job
she has no boundaries and relies on me
to do the majority of the work
and to be her therapist and uh emotional
and mental support in the end she gets
the same amount of credit as i do
regardless who does
work here are my questions what do you
do when someone is bad at their job
because of mental health
is that an excuse also is the fact that
she's a black woman in a company that
has little diversity
means she should get extra consideration
and leeway if she's not good at her job
what should i do as an individual making
less money than her i wish sometime
i wish someone hadn't told me that who
is taking the brunt of the negative
effects of the poor performance
i feel like i can't quit because my
previous job hunting experience and also
should i be expected to love your
consideration
love hearing your perspective on the pod
it's a toughy it's tough because they
who whoever hired her didn't do a good
job because it's not that she's
what did she say she said person who
hired her was black kid
she said she doesn't first thing she
doesn't have the needed experience yeah
so already the guy it sounds like the
guy hired her just like drove around
yeah yeah exactly um so you're setting
hires like this like sympathy hires not
hey three four qualified people one of
them has to be black let's give the
black person an opportunity that's what
people are
generally saying i know there's other
like affirmative action blah blah blah
i'm just saying in this one you're not
helping this
push for diversity because you're not
hiring a
this isn't a diversity area this is a
incompetence hire
yeah well i feel like it's gonna happen
uh this probably
happened is happening a lot right now
meaning
for all of the people that were
qualified
and didn't get jobs and got jobs they're
doing great
because they're talented and then there
are a bunch of people who didn't
des aren't talented and weren't getting
jobs and then got jobs
and now people are like [ __ ] i think
it's probably a lot less than you think
you know just because you can make a
good case that this person knows the
[ __ ] he's doing but
the guilt or the let's try this thing
new i i think you're right
i'm sure there's a lot but i don't i
don't know how many people are gonna
[ __ ] up their
job and they're from there from what i
can tell on earth
off the top 30 percent that's off the
top
on every job i've ever had 30 but that's
the problem
think of every job you've ever had think
of the amount of people that were
terrible at their job
yeah oh yeah so that's the right i'm not
saying like they're all black
no no no i know like we're just talking
about non-white
but now the hire has
extra weight on them because they are a
diversity higher let's say even though
we've all worked in jobs where there
were so many unqualified people
they just happened to be we weren't even
either they were white or we're not
talking about it we don't frame it that
way so
well you don't frame that way if you're
white
i'm sure the black people are like this
white [ __ ]
but it's like you don't say when it's
your group you don't mind
but that's not my concern but when it's
another group you're like this [ __ ]
can you believe it
these [ __ ] asians um um
tell me i don't this is one of those
things where normally i say eat it
but this feels like too much to eat
and in this case i don't know i
would keep looking for a job and
um because you also don't want to snitch
no and there's a title yes like it and
there's the emotional
aspect of the woman having anxiety and
depression and yeah not wanting to [ __ ]
up her life
it's this is a one of them things well
i wonder if i don't know
can we just have a subpar output
i don't what do you mean in that but
like why do we have to
because if she was white you'd [ __ ]
get rid of her
right or maybe if she was a white man
i think easier to get rid of right now
yeah i think white whim i don't that i
can't
speak to i just mean because it said
yeah he never even gets a job
2021 no you can't get a job sorry you
can't they they try to take my pie they
tried to fire me from my own podcast
um maybe they wanted more color i said
you guys how much do you need
i bought a red table come on red tables
makes bianca i got bianca's shirt no one
shirt
um yes so i don't know
i this is above my this is usually i
have
i don't know what to do i don't know
what to do
you're a lori lightfooting yeah i don't
know what
i don't want to make this choice okay i
i don't know what to do
look for to put some feelers out there
um
as it were no pun intended and
try to leave and then this is one of
those things where you just wink on the
way out
right like where they go how was lisa
and you go
you know what she grew a lot
or something that's not a compliment
faint praise
say uh medium talent um
yeah uh but i don't know what to do i'd
say that's really tough
keep up the keep up keep pulling out of
voiper
you're more than your weight and look
and
put out go on uh linkedin or whatever
monster.com whoever's anybody
go on betterhelp sponsoring this week
uh goodbye thanks elastane er had a
little hoe face
in my 20s and then i thought i wanted to
get married and dated
in my 30s um these apps
wait i had a little then thought i
wanted to get married
i know but and dated in my 30s
i don't know what the [ __ ] she's saying
these apps are just torture for me and i
find my spell self still single at 41.
and i think i'm
good uh with that but i do be wanting
sex
especially after the year we've had with
working at home and so much alone time
so i think i want to get back on the app
but just for sex
without the horseshit of dating
one wrinkle is that a little over two
years ago i had my breasts and nipples
removed
i had the brca genetic mutation that i
had
my breasts removed uh preventatively to
avoid cancer 60 to 90
of getting into my lifetime it was a
good decision and a huge deal in my life
so i'm glad i did it i did get breast
reconstruction so in clothes
you'd never know that i had quote work
done i do have scars and i'd be
real i'd be a real dick to let a partner
uh
just find out pre-coitus so i will need
to get a little heavy with someone on an
app
and i don't know the best way to go
about it while still
keeping the encounter super light so my
query is
twofold um best way to get
uncomplicated dick at 41 and also how do
i let men know that my titty game is
weak
actually non-existent feel think beale
bonk etc etc
well she has boobs right that's what i'm
unclear on
right if you have boobs what's the
problem
and i've also heard of people getting
nipples tattooed on
in these situations that the brca
like it's just the breast tissue
it's not you know when some people have
the giant scars
across their boobs that's reduction
that's reduction that's the anchor scar
okay or isn't there somewhere people
have breast cancer and
it's just like a large scar yeah i think
that's
tig had that from her special or yeah
like really big scars
i don't is that this i think if it's
reconstruction
i don't know uh look at breast
reconstruction
oh yeah amita look at that line oh right
uh i see that the woman on the right i
think uh
i'm just wondering how
i've seen people get that tattooed so
the nipple
yeah oh mita look yeah
that looks so awful um
yeah so so i get
i mean i would suggest getting a nipple
tattoo
and uh of course get a how neal feel
logo
stupid why not um that's on the house
you know that's on the house um
and if not because first of all i think
the uh the
guy the just that lump is pretty
it gets me 80 of the way there meaning
just like uh
even with no nipple i'm like yeah right
she's she's lump
yeah like even with no nipple i'm like
that's a boob
i don't know any guys with that you know
what i mean i mean i know a few guys
let's be honest but like i don't know
any guys with a
thing that looks like a boob with no
nipple
so uh either get a tattooed
or because i don't my point was i don't
guys
i don't believe anyone actually cares
about nipples i think it's a thing that
you
it's like visit the gift shop yeah it's
like well
they're there i want to do something to
them
the nipple's sensitive but not really
compared to
other you know other parts of the body
and uh mostly most
with most women in my experience of
course
firsthand firsthand firsthand firsthand
and so get a tattoo and if not
keep your shirt on or keep like keep
like
really draining bra on yeah
um but her question is okay we're
texting we're chatting on an app
do you want to know beforehand should i
be like oh you know i
think she's a yeah i think she's
overestimating
guys fear level i think she should just
say it right before be like by the
no i just that's that's guys well you
could literally go
i need a hundred dollars and a guy will
be fine get
hot and heavy how do i get an
ejaculation with you
yes so hot and heavy kissing boom boom
you go to take off no no i just
i don't know my boobs like i had i just
have a blank blank blank yeah i'm
i don't think you need to cover it up
you just go you know angelina jolie
because she had this surgery yeah
she's hot right you like her you want to
[ __ ] her i
have the same breast thing as her okay
so just either
just keep it right and the guy will be
like a guy's not gonna care
i just i promise you he's not gonna care
like you're good and if you say i feel
more comfortable like blink blink blink
he's
like whatever gets to sex and that's
what you want
yes you both want the same thing yeah
what what is it it begins with an a
ejaculation that's right
somebody make a song
you guys mentioned i'll show you in a
recent episode that i was shocked to
hear that someone is bianca
was so anti-australian going as far as
to do an unflattering
impression of our accent though accurate
as an aussie listener i considered
writing him previously to ask your
thoughts in australia
especially around neil's u.s escape
plans
uh this guy then comes with a bunch of
um oh wow sorry i'm sure i do
i don't need to bore you with details on
how well we handle covet and how amazing
our beaches and food culture
is but i did want to focus on dismissing
some of binky's fears so she might honor
us
with her presence here down under
perhaps for her next
hashtag [ __ ] fats
i did some research and in australia
between 2000 2013 there were only 27
deaths from snake bites
an average of just two people per year
this is these are good stats
and as for spiders it will shock you
discover there have been no
fatal spider bites since
okay cool zero deaths sure they're big
as [ __ ] and sometimes eat birds
but they can't hurt you they just make
you [ __ ] your pants
uh you know who else eats birds pretty
much every animal
including humans especially humans relax
they don't not jump out and die and not
end
i don't eat birds yeah you don't but
others do
um though this i'm that was clear my
throat for everyone
listening um you know who you are um
[Music]
though this one unlucky bloke got bit in
the dick twice
by a snake apparently uh
[Laughter]
all right well yeah with the nature dogs
they make it seem
frightening in your planet your planet
seems frightening to me
but i've been getting i've been getting
a lot of dms i've read all your dm's
i am sorry i'm not trying to insult
people will try to
take it to death threats guys huh let's
take this up a notch
some more interesting uh quick myths to
confirm or deny vegemite is delicious
nope kangaroos are often seen in the
suburban streets
we don't drink fosters it isn't even for
sale here
shrimps are prawns and we rarely
barbecue them
toilets flush normal uh question see
here's the thing
the amount of australian friends i have
that say
you will never see a kangaroo jumping
down the street and then this guy's
saying you do
yeah people have different experiences
they gotta get it together
[Music]
some women have very sensitive nipples
others do not
know
[Music]
like neil i'm a huge fan of ice cream
almost to the point where i can't stop
eating it
at least once sometime two some at least
one sometimes two bowls a night
to try to eat less of it i've tried
things like only buying one or two
liter tubs for the month but
that's gone within a week or less and
then i'll just end up eating more
mainly due to stress eating staying at
home and the state home order in ontario
grad school blah blah blah
i like the idea of ice and ice cream
night and was curious if yours is weekly
monthly
and things you do to help yourself stick
to that schedule thanks
well great that's good question
um it's every two weeks used to be once
a week now it's every
two weeks okay um
the thing about sugar is once you get
out of that three-day window
you don't crave it my
i do have ice cream that's right it is
if you get out
if you can if you're a sugar person and
you break out of like three days
you're it's so much easier okay to you
just don't
crave it like chemically like you eat
sugar every
day i'm an american aren't i no
i don't but i'm saying like i mean like
added sugar like
something everyone does dude like every
in america
the their sugar and spaghetti says sugar
[ __ ] everywhere
but like okay i don't have a sweet tooth
at all of course there's sugar in things
right even starches turned to sugar so
blah blah but
i'm wait what i'm kidding so i mean
do you candy cookie cakes
ice cream i eat sugar-free gum a lot of
it
um and candies
cookies i i i
i you buy when i'm out of the window i
don't
but if i'm at a thing if i'm at dinner
and someone orders dessert i'm like [ __ ]
i'm gonna i can't control myself it's
weird when we were on the we're on the
first class flight to uh
tc oh they had so much good food and all
you ate was cookies
and i was like have you had cookies
if you have a sweet tooth there's
nothing you can do about it i just want
sugar all the time so it all of it just
translates to
delicious i mean i i had to
it was getting wild even once a week i
wouldn't eat dinner
and i would just like cake it was wild
it was graphic it was graphic content
in this house and this house of me and
willard
blessed house uh yeah it was wild
it got why i would just get make myself
sick
oh it's such an addiction yeah i just
it was also because i was only doing it
once a week i was like i had live it up
and the it's like with fasting where
your body
kind of resets and so now i'm just
ayahuasca might have helped less
dependent on sugar so
every two weeks you have an ice cream
party yeah and now it's like
half a pint maybe a pint if i don't eat
dinner
is it pint the square or the no the like
the ben and jerry's one
it's no big deal and
and then are they always like do you do
sugar-free ice cream
no i don't even do vegan ice cream i do
do
regular creamy creamy stuff yeah uh
are you gonna eat ice cream after this i
don't can't remember if i'm
if it's tonight or tomorrow when my ice
cream night is
usually i had on my in my calendar do
you feel
shameful when you do it no like
afterwards
no it's just more about it i just didn't
want to be
i wanted my body to be norm i wanted my
body to be like healthy i just didn't
want to be like
i was eating ice cream every night at
one point and that's why
yeah i'd show up at the store with it
everybody thought it was hilarious
that's good
um people look people loved it don't get
me wrong but it's
gross just gross like that concentration
of sugar
and i like god i have it every night
it's disgusting do you
think it was uh did you notice do you
notice changes when you're eating ice
cream then when you're not
or you just feel it's better on ice
cream nights i don't
really feel great afterward because it's
your
you spike and you it's kind of gross is
it just like a lot
like is it a sugar is addictive that
whole
food addiction craving or is it help you
feel better
in your day i like a regimen we all know
that yes
um i'm due to have sex at 8 20 tonight
hurry up
if you guys get out of here i need to a
jaguar
uh
i i like having a discipline system even
with
snacks i can't i had well i can't
i had to start getting individually
yeah i have individually wrapped um
snacks like but it's not even snacks
it's like [ __ ] cranberries and
almonds yeah and you just would get eat
them
i couldn't buy a whole bag because i
couldn't meet out i'm my own fourth
grade son
is what i is what it is so i i would
just
eat too much i got pretzels
at costco against my better judgment
a giant bag i've been packing i've been
hacking away at them
your addictions are i just don't know
yeah too many pretzels yeah um
i like my kerosene lamps and i and i
so i i just don't i
like to eat what i'll during dinner time
because i can't control it
do you have an addictive personality
with other things or is this just like a
food related
specifically um i've never really had a
drug issue
no cigarettes that kind of gets a lot of
people
and um oxycontin does that count
no i've never really had a drug problem
i don't like the way drugs make me feel
um most of them just stomach me i don't
uh but even opioids i think i have
might have have i may have some now
i had it for some maybe when i got the
nose thing done
he gave me like like four oh i yeah i
had something done and they gave me
these things called t3 which are tylenol
number three
they're very hot very strong tylenol
coated in
oxycodone i think they're just like
they're like
codeine just coding coding yeah what's
oxycodone and
oxycodeine i don't know uh
numbered tylenol number three literally
just put in tylenol number three buddy
thank you hit him with a buddy just
three okay fine
oral drug
acetaminophen and coding yeah and that i
was
so off of that i was yeah i don't like
so many feelings i have so many at home
like i don't want these
i don't know how people this is how
people get robbed that's why i was kind
of vague about mine
these people so i guess there is
something there rob in this house no
they want yeah
i have three and if you can find them
bless you um so i don't
so i just need to be my whole family's
like that
everybody has everyone's i didn't even
realize it
probably 15 years ago sarah silverman
one time goes brennan's don't like
snacks and i was like
how did you she just noticed it you guys
are all observant
yeah um no sarah give sarah the question
sarah
i know there's letters and [ __ ] i'm
supposed to write but i i
just but just have will make the noise
i don't think that was it i don't know
not a good noise doesn't make sense to
anyone but you
and that's not a big enough audience for
us i've got a question about
thank you i've got a question about what
people say to each other as a family in
their own homes
oh i'm referring to all the racist and
crazy things
that a family says to each other not
about different ethnic
ethnic groups i'm a white guy who has an
asian islander for a partner
and we have a kid who's mixed one of our
favorite things is to make stereotypical
asian comments
in extremely offensive voices while we
cook and do things around the house
i'll go on record right now a very
satisfying thing to do
um in recent years we have learned to
keep our voices down at the grocery
store but occasionally i'll get a dirty
look
from some white becky who uh it's
actually a white
uh karen who heard my bad my lie
impression until she sees i'm with a
couple
of crazy rich asians my partner is a
hair stylist the other day she was
discussing this topic with the jewish
woman
how i would love to hear what gets said
in that house all caps
and we both suddenly realized that maybe
we aren't so [ __ ] up after all what do
you think is this a normal thing that
families do
is it okay for white people and mixed
families to lean into the race-based
jokes
he's asking two different questions yeah
um
because i thought it was about what
families say to each other
not about different ethnic groups right
so and then he asked what about i think
groups
right um you go
you know i love a i had a joke in three
mics about
um uh doing an impression of
someone's accent uh and
chappelle show largely is
uh me and dave making fun of each
other's race
is kind of i mean that's part of you
know there you go
um and so
yeah i'm i'm all for it yeah i'm all for
it obviously i
you can be all for it there are there
are ones that are
like the be one of the one of the more
popular obscure ones
from chappelle was and then we just do
the jingle just did the
wind chime part we cut it down make it
winches beautiful
um that white people black people use
washcloths
and white people don't right that had
never really been on tv before right
who was hurt by that right you know what
i mean it's just a weird
yeah or like most people who aren't
white
wash their meat like they do not wash
their meat correct or
apparently a lot of white people don't
wash their legs obviously people know
why i don't wash my legs but that's a
big
not why oh yeah cause you think enough
soap gets [ __ ] it's
fine never had a dirty leg in my life
you don't know that
i i do because i would have or it didn't
make a difference it didn't do enough to
infect me
um so
i think if it's within your house yeah
but
at the grocery store you're doing
[ __ ] asian bits
yeah right what are you doing buddy uh
one time a friend of mine who was indian
and i would
just i don't know why we just got into i
think this was in
high school and we just got into doing
an indian accent with each other
and it was funny and we thought it was
hilarious and i realized i started doing
it
when he wasn't around at the bank and
and mind you it was my
indian accent got very good i don't
think it was a great accent but it was
better what you were trying to do i took
his accent his accent was of his
is essentially his mom or something yeah
so mine became
top-tier indian accent but
i just started noticing i'm doing it
away from
the protected source and i'm no longer
protected like
at the bank yeah and so i just i was
like we can't do this i can't
discern like my gut reaction is to do
the accent everywhere now
and i i look crazy i can't do this
accent to people like no
so there's also
there's there's just it's not even code
switching it's more like
no that's not really the tone of
if i'm texting like with roy and trayvon
there's like a there's a level there's a
type of joke we make
that we might not make around other
people
sure you know what i mean it's like
dirty laundry not literally dirty
laundry jokes but like
[ __ ] that you wouldn't say probably
around a lot of white people
right for instance and they know that
i'm like good for it
neil i'm not you know what i mean like
black man here
thank you like i'm not gonna
take it and weaponize it right but
you also can't text that's everybody
right i can't then go i just talked to
so-and-so
now you just have to make strict rules
of
when we do our miley mylay
voice and then when you don't sir you
can't do it outside
goodbye you've got shalom from the home
binco nardo
nardo lseniar pleasantries all that jazz
um i've heard you speak on the topic
several times the last episode you also
touched on not
owing people you break up with specific
reasons as to why
be because of not wanting to put in the
effort for a dead relationship or just
because it can be soul-crushing for the
recipient and that's polite
uh most recently banks referred to it
not being her responsibility but
specifically because
it wasn't a particularly long or serious
relationship
i recently broke up with a woman who
i've been with for nearly six years the
last two
we were engaged because of the length of
seriousness of the relationship
i am am i obligated to explain the
specifics of why it didn't work out for
me
or can i just let things pass like the
both of you seem to believe is
acceptable
we've talked about it to an extent but i
feel bad bringing up the small details
that make me feel like i'm picking her
apart from for an excuse
uh most simply put we were young and
have grown apart in ways we didn't
predict because shocker you still have a
lot of growing to do
even when you start to think you're a
quote real adult we're both in our
mid-20s now
oh god for reference i'm 26 and she's
24. no i was too young
who knew who and why bank think um
no it's we grew apart it can
a lot of times it can just come down to
habits
if you say i do this you don't seem to
like it or want to
do it with me and
that's not an accusation um
you can just say like your level of
passion or interest is
doesn't match much that's it by the way
that's a good breakup thing
my love your level of passion does not
match
right but no well the problem is that i
could
the person hearing that can be like no
one's like
you know i am a dispassionate person
that doesn't have a
bernie sanders i love motocross or
whatever this guy's interests are
right most neil howellfield listeners
love motocross um by the way there has
been a spike
in tuesday listeners because i think
people don't want to not
be one um so
we shamed them into there uh so i don't
think you can
i still think you can be vague about it
because i promise you whatever your
problems are
are not gonna be the same ones that the
next person has
i mean maybe they will be but maybe they
won't be i just mean
to your point about just really quick
the passionate thing
someone could be like i can i know
people like no i can learn i can i want
it
you know but i don't want to force you
into that i know what you mean
i know what you mean because people take
that as like well either i'm passionate
or i can learn to
you know you never told me you wanted me
to have those interests you don't we're
not all we don't have to be interested
in the same thing
i feel like it leaves it open to to for
them to
say i'll change yeah and then it's like
oh but
but my thing is with any of these things
i don't need you to change i don't want
you to change
i don't want you to not i don't need you
to change
your interests i'm not your son
right you know what i mean where you
have to drive me to you
i want you bad and if i want you bad and
you're telling me reasons they have to
be reasons i can't
rationalize around i gotta [ __ ] other
girls two
a day actually two two call girls a day
i wonder if that the call girl economy
could even support that
i don't know how many that's 700 call
girls a
a year and then 700 girls a year
and well i wonder if there are 700 call
girls well maybe if it's like
if there's a way to maybe we can ask
bill gates to help us figure out
if there's 10 billion i mean if
anybody's got a puzzle
if we have to just there's i feel
emphasis i don't think i i
don't say it very much on here algorithm
i said it before i was like you don't
say [ __ ]
i kind of don't even say i like when you
say [ __ ] people love it
um people don't love it uh
you don't know where anything and i
think we grew apart is good and
and then just lean into your feelings
also
have i think you should for the person
being broken up with
have whatever level of closure they need
if it's just like okay but can you
please like
some people do get stuck you know so i'm
not saying you have to say
i was gonna ask that do you think that i
don't know anyone who
ever thinks if you go five years later
anyone thinks we should still be
together
you it always you always get information
or you change your life in a way that
it it's it it makes it better
yeah like you're like glad i don't know
anyone who's like oh
martha [ __ ] moths why are they
[ __ ] mods um
um i think it's because
the people who also regret is i think
very painful so a lot of people
aren't uh even the people who regret
like hey maybe i could have appreciated
that person more or i was immature i
wasn't ready
they're even you're right they're still
not saying i would they're just like
i [ __ ] it up yeah i think everyone
looks back and goes i
could have been better but
i don't know anyone who's like we should
still be
with each other right she should be here
right now
you just life's good look that way right
where it you'll find a way to okay
it's that thing of like uh the
regressing to the mean where people who
when the lottery
go back to where they were before the
lottery and people who lose their legs
same thing right and it's it's
good and bad it's good in if you lose
your legs
it's bad it's a lot of if you win the
lottery um really
quick when he says you know we say we
didn't owe it
i think that is before you get into a
relationship
i think you have free reign to not share
i think you have free reign to share as
much of your energy with someone why
you're not
talking to them anymore as you want
you're pretty good but you don't go
into specifics you just be like i'm not
i'm talking before you enter a
relationship
[Music]
what what about it well because he said
you know you guys say
it's not really your responsibility but
that's before going into a relationship
i think he's talking about you we both
agree that like you don't
tell the person what they did wrong
before you're in a relationship but once
you're in a relationship i think you do
have some degree of like when you're
breaking up right
yeah when you're breaking up you think
you should tell somebody with what
level of commitment are you talking
about you dated
you he was your boyfriend for a year and
a half
and you guys are breaking out or you
want to break up with him
he's kind of like why i think you should
say something oh that's
the less i didn't know that and nobody
in america knew that
or australia uh no because he says i
said because it wasn't particularly long
or serious
oh you believe that after a certain
amount you
should tell them tell them something i
mean you don't just
hang up the phone no of course not i'll
i think we grew apart
is adequate right so you don't do
specifics on no matter what
try to keep it on yourself i don't like
i don't
hear another good one is i don't have
the same
feeling i had when we a year ago
than when we were dating a year ago i
don't have the same
energy the same amount of like looking
forward to it
and you deserve it that's where you go
you put it on them
you deserve that level of energy and i i
can't
do it anymore i do what you do i don't
put it on them i'm not like well you did
it i'm always like look like we're
arguing
you're like you can put it into like
happiness or like and
like i just it's not working out is the
point
so you can owe them something but
i don't know six years i don't know this
seems like
it's you can't they don't even know by
the way not formed
her frontal lobe she's 24. so just sort
of tell her
you're 25. you're amygdala is informed
lady this isn't working i'm here with a
complete amygdala
and you're [ __ ] over there amygdala's
not formed yet okay
or it's the frontal lobe uh are there
for this
the frontal cortex would have been funny
because it's got the heart okay
okay goodbye you've got hello banks
on your latest show you spoke about
comparing yourself to others on the
planet to acknowledge the good in your
life
here's a helpful pep talk for when
you're feeling down on yourself okay
one do you have access to clean water
yes
then great job you're doing better than
33
of the world's population do you have
access to a toilet
yes way to go you're doing better than
most people on our
60 of the population do not have access
to a toilet
that's crazy and i'm not talking about
people at starbucks who are not
customers
and can't get the code talking about 4.5
billion
[ __ ] people bill gates big toilet guy
trying to figure that out he is and
[ __ ]
[ __ ] along the way if he [ __ ] a
little bit along the way and i get a
toilet out of it what do i who gets hurt
melinda french gates is who gets hurt do
you have a full-time job where you
make more than 16 an hour sweet you make
34 000
which puts you in the richest one
percent of the world's earners
oh wow do you suffer from malaria no
excellent since 40 of the world lives in
malaria risk zones
with a million people a year dying from
it that's another bill gates
area um and you know what's
disappointingly effective like not
glamorous because when you go on
charity navigate or any of these things
nets yeah
just buy nets for people it's like can't
i do what
well and it does nets we need nets
um i why because i was i remember
hearing about malaria and how it's the
number one killer and i
googled why we don't have malaria here
because we have screens it was just
screens and
closure window campaigns in the 40s and
like 50s a lot of moths though
do you have internet yes you're in the
top 59
of the globe do you listen to how neil
feel each word for free yes
what more could you ask for a lot of
these are bill gates
internet yep twitter anchor
better help music and talk those are the
sponsors
you don't you get it for free but you
gotta listen and you gotta go and better
help
and uh you know promo code
but seriously do it you don't have to do
it for us but
it helps if it helps if you go on
goodbye
love the podcast please bring back the
champs that [ __ ] was hilarious
no thanks i have a question if vaccines
take
uh vaccines takes years to test
and this one year roll out of the coven
vaccine was expedited because of the
pandemic
how do they have different flu vaccine
each year from what i understand
uh this guy's he's wondering how the flu
vaccine works
but because you came here i'll tell you
they
uh they have a different they get uh
six months ahead and they and then part
of its guess
guessing goodbye
r l s t i n e or whatever
i just watched in and of itself
streaming on hulu
after a friend emphatically recommended
it i fell in love with the film and was
emotionally shook and intrigued
throughout the entire performance
cried for the first time in a long time
i'd love to hear a neil and bianca
review this one
i believe this should be viewed without
any knowledge of what it is go in blind
and enjoy the ride
sir do you want us to tell people about
it or not
don't i haven't seen it as i don't you
still haven't seen it
no you have to see it because i keep
forgetting in and of itself
on hulu starring my good friend derek
uh a great show that i saw live
and watched that on hulu and it's one of
the only
specials i've ever seen that is
filmed uh
in a way that adds to it
like he they there's some cut twos and
stuff that obviously weren't in there
but it's
very very well it's [ __ ] immaculately
dude
frank oz directed it the thing i
i don't always love watching magic it's
so i have to i'm trying to get myself
into places barely
it's i it that's the category it
falls under but it's not really magic
okay
watch a half hour if you if you don't
like it you can you're free to go
okay and i will never forgive you
goodbye okay
love the weekly doc check-ins and i'll
admit to using your show as a filter
review system before docs i watch
tuesday listener thursday doc watcher
sir
that's not a category however i've tried
to set a standard for
any non-fiction content doc news or
books that i consume number one the
subject
isn't clearly evil or bad for society
not interested in watching how terrible
people can be
trump slash murder docs number two
the subject isn't clearly intel
is clear the subject isn't clearly less
intelligent than me
not interested in learning how stupid
people can be
uh tiger king some reality tv how do you
feel about watching evil and stupid
people does it ever feel
like it just it's just normalizing
ignorance and immorality
uh sir a lot of documentary you're
yeah i was like you're like [ __ ] on
a lot of good
you're throwing away a lot of good
content here with these standards
it's true like what do you watch right
what isn't about murder in some way or
death or
or people people stupid
what stories do you like
like i can't even i can't even think of
anything i'm trying to like
is it i don't i don't like epstein
that's that's negative he's
maybe he's intelligent but then you
could make a claim maybe he's not i
don't know
i'm trying to think of he's got as dumb
of speaking voice as you've ever heard
it's unbelievable he's a little it's
michael collins um
self-aggrandizement yeah um
take a doc take a good dock see if we
can [ __ ] art of killing
are they active yeah active killer
that's that's killing title in the title
um showa uh
blackmailed to death blackfish
[ __ ] black is full of stupid stupid
people and murder
like look up netflix docs like best
documentary or something
my octopus teacher okay i mean yeah if
you want to watch my octopus teacher
you're not smarter than an octopus but
also
well i didn't like octopus teacher
athlete a it's about
uh sexually abusing young women
c-spiricy is
negative uh yeah tell me who i am
negative
great hack negative social dilemma
negative
last breath i mean literally every
single fire festival
all of this is bad for handy annoying um
he was in character the whole i don't
care
he just sounded like a [ __ ] nightmare
to deal with yeah but he was dude i
don't care the movie didn't do good
and he seemed like a nightmare uh
block but there you go last blockbuster
sir it's about the flash blockbuster and
if you enjoy that
there's also one about tower records
called
i think the last record store or
something that tom hanks son colin
directed
not chet hayes and
it is not white boy summer
it's the more mature colin hanks
and it's it's i guess all things must
pass
is the name of the documentary it's
about tower records and nothing bad
happens in fact
the guy who directed it is the son of
america
mr america tom hanks he wants the music
docs
like behind the music but they're all
all those
not yeah okay you're it's you're 90
of [ __ ] is that yeah so sir i don't know
um good luck during oscar season with
those movies because you're in for a
real nightmare
um i
i'm not only i not only do i not have to
take this [ __ ] i
don't want to no i'm no longer
interested in taking it
he's over it thank you all for listening
bye thanks you guys
[Music]